Google and Facebook topping the global
digital advertising market last year
seeing this incredibly large company
getting involved in almost every area of
calm big tech media companies they're
actively silencing a circuit what I'm
saying is we gotta break these guys of
course you want to run a platform that's
fine you don't get to run a whole bunch
of the business in there
Google handles 88% of search traffic in
America Facebook has more than 2.4
billion active monthly users and it's
projected that half of us online retail
will go through Amazon by 2020 there are
calls from both sides of the aisle to
break up the tech giants to strip them
of liability protections for what others
say on their platforms and to impose new
regulations that would stop them from
misusing the personal information of
their customers but there's also a
growing movement among some of the web's
pioneering thinkers and software
developers to come up with technological
solutions to countering the growing
power of Facebook Amazon Twitter and
Google the goal is to build a new
decentralized web there are so many
different possible ways of
decentralizing the internet and what's
lacking is the legal right to
interoperate and the legal support to
stop dirty tricks from preventing you
from exercising that legal right Cory
Doctorow is a science fiction author and
tech journalist at Boing Boing who's
been thinking and writing about the web
since it was introduced by Tim
berners-lee in the early 1990s
berners-lee and other web pioneers dr. o
points out intended for their creation
to be decentralized an open source the
cyber utopian view was not merely that
season the means of information would
make you free but that failing to do so
would put you in perpetual chains well
there are a lot of reasons to want a
more decentralized diffused pluralistic
Internet it's hard to imagine that
anyone is competent to make great
decisions for two and a half billion
people is there any reason to seriously
doubt that this will just take care of
itself that more people will do what you
have done and log off Facebook the
collective-action problem of everyone
deciding that it's time to leave
Facebook is a really hard one and as we
see it's not getting easier because even
when you do leave Facebook by and large
you end up on a service that's owned by
Facebook there are many theories about
why the web became centralized dr. o
largely blames the abuse of intellectual
property law to defeat the decentralized
free software movement which was
championed by the activist and
programmer Richard Stallman who helped
create the popular open-source operating
system Linux but today
hackers are divided between the old
values and the new imagine if you bought
a house and the basement was locked and
only the original building contractor
had the key if you needed to make a
change repair anything you have to go to
him and if he was too busy doing
something else he'd tell you to get lost
and he'd be stuck when Richard Stallman
walked into a lab at MIT and found that
someone had put a lock on the drawer
where they kept the paper tapes for the
computer and he was like what do you
mean I can't take that paper tape out
and change the holes punched in it I'm a
computer scientist I'm gonna recreate
all of the holes in that paper tape and
make a clone of Unix past in 1998 the
Digital Millennium Copyright Act became
an impediment to the open and
permissionless approach to software
development the law was intended to
prevent duplication of Hollywood movies
but it was eventually applied to all
software breaking digital locks to learn
from and approve upon the code of
dominant web platforms became a federal
crime today's tech companies use IP to
shield their proprietary code from
would-be competitors and so this thicket
of exclusive rights around products that
can be invoked to prevent new entrants
for making add-ons compatible products
or even competing products has made it
very hard for new entrants to emerge and
I think is in large part responsible for
the concentration in the industry and
all of that thicket exists today because
people who made their money as
insurgents spent that money to keep
their newfound power despite the legal
and political challenges dr. o outlines
there are innovators attempting to
create new decentralized ecosystems of
web services
this former Christian Science church in
San Francisco houses the Internet
Archive a digital repository of more
than 50 petabytes of images movies and
texts the organization has also archived
more than 330 billion web pages the
archives mission is to make all of
mankind's knowledge available online
forever to everyone for free which is a
pretty big vision tonight Mitra Arden
who's the internet archives head of
decentralization says the history of the
web is too important to be held in
custody by a single organization he's
overseeing a plan to migrate the
internet archives more than 50 million
gigabytes of data to a distributed
network in which the information is
spread out among a storage network
maintained by users the decentralized
web now is in the state that the early
web was back in the early 90s right so
there's a lot of things that work on a
small scale don't walk on a large scale
we're a large-scale site but we also
cite that if we put up decentralized
webbing it breaks we don't have our
whole business model contingent upon it
a beta version of this peer-to-peer
network is already operating and
publicly accessible I think what it
would look like is a world where servers
were everywhere that your internet
router at home would also be a server
and those servers would talk to each
other and the interface may look very
similar to what it is now except you
wouldn't be controlled by the branding
so the user interface and the data would
be suffered now the user interface and
the data inextricably tied together but
Cory Doctorow doesn't think the
decentralized web can take off without
government intervention he agrees with
Elizabeth Warren that the Federal Trade
Commission should break up the tech
giants if you had your way Facebook
would have to sell off Instagram Amazon
would have to sell off all those little
businesses that they're running
competing businesses yep how cool is the
federal government to tell these
companies they have to do that oh
there's antitrust law it's been around
for more than a hundred years if you
have a bunch of tech companies that got
giant by doing exactly the same things
that all the other companies through
history that God giant doing that we
used to ban and that we stop banning
right when the tech industry started
maybe we could just try and forcing
those rules again why would the focus be
on antitrust and not on you know
reforming intellectual property laws I
saw I think you've got a logical or
where you want a logical and we do need
structural separation we do need to
break Facebook up so that it can no
longer engage in this anti-competitive
behavior but that's just part of a set
of reasons to do both I guess the part
that I am a little bit confused about is
the sense in which these companies are
monopolies sure because yes Google
dominates search amazon dominates online
shopping but of course there are
competitors they're buying up potential
competitors all the time and adding new
technologies to their portfolio but what
sense does that make them a monopoly I
may not make them a monopoly but it
makes them monopolistic okay right in
the history of antitrust a monopoly is
not the only game in town a monopoly
exerts so much gravity that it distorts
the market are there any promising
technological solutions to this
decentralizing the web I think we have
all the tech I mean well it'll need
constant evolution and maintenance but
like it's all out there web 3.0 has this
wonderful set of trust baked into the
internet itself Molly McKinley is a
former Google programmer and current
project lead of ipfs the interplanetary
file system a communications protocol
that's meant to replace the system by
which most of us access the web now
through hypertext Transfer Protocol that
is the HTTP you see in your web browser
while HTTP connects your computer to a
particular server IP FS scours the
network for a piece of content and
connects you to whomever happens to be
hosting it video you want to watch the
document you want to load the website
you want to go to by what it is you're
trying to view not who you're trying to
get it from and that that changed that
kind of simple seeming switch and how
you organize things makes huge ripple
effects and differences in what sort of
tools you're empowered to build think of
natural disasters or censorship or other
cases like that where people lose access
to content on the
today you want them to continue being
able to collaborate and organize with
each other and communicate and rely on
these sorts of technologies and tools
why would people host contents right now
obviously the answer is you make money
by having the computer that hosts the
content and serves it to people
many people will join that cause because
they believe in that cause and help make
sure that Wikipedia or other data sets
like that that we really care about
continue to be backed up purely
altruistic ly but you can also end up in
models tit for tat for lack of a better
word we're like okay you host my photo
content and all host yours and this way
both of us have backup so if either one
of our machines goes down there's a
backup of content and we can you know do
that with a whole group of friends and
you are providing me are really useful
service and I'm participating in that
Network and then finally you can end up
in models of like storage for hire and
so file point which is in development is
an incentivized storage network by
serving data by storing people's data
you can earn a cryptographic token
McKinley sees the decentralized web as a
way to sidestep the dangers of
government regulation and even
authoritarian control a decentralized
framework where there isn't that
middleman that can be manipulated or
coerced or regulated into exposing your
data that's a better safer more
resilient world which doesn't end up in
this case where it's susceptible to
authoritarian manipulation control we
didn't take a broad enough view of our
responsibilities and that was a big
mistake and it was my mistake and I'm
sorry these two almost contradictory
narratives that I see in one is that the
web is too centralized there are these
big companies controlling everything and
then especially out of Congress you hear
that it's too anarchic too decentralized
trolls hateful people disinformation and
we need to be able to control it and
there's a certain convenience to being
able to call Mark Zuckerberg in front of
Congress absolutely so we get a choice
now whether we're gonna fix big tech or
fix the internet but we don't get to do
both if we decide
that we're going to give Big Tex
state-like duties to prevent bad action
on their platforms we require them to be
big enough to do so and we put a floor
under how small we can allow them to
become if you make tech smaller it's
harder to suborn them to act as arms of
the state I think that's a feature or
not a bug we don't want to allow one
person's judgment to be the be-all and
end-all of how the rest of us have to
conduct our lives we want to have checks
on their authority and one of the ways
that you get checks on the on someone's
authority is by allowing the people who
live under that authority to go
somewhere else